we came here expecting 0-6 we came here
without real preparation we didn't
bootcamp in Korea and we were like okay
guys we'll just come and play our game
but today today we're in quarterfinals
well sure and all I want to say is that
hey guys we are from wild car and they
have told you before being underdog
doesn't mean being a loser
gets it now the table jumps in the wall
good propel the tons gonna live in the
curls oh how much more do they have keep
the last little bit ready to react to nd
situated
- captain she's available damage plans
comes out who he's down to get another
shot through but what happened right
after that is 680 - [ __ ] - - now they
might bear though this is gonna work
look at the mini-map CEO Cheon de alva
Schnucks
they're gonna cigarettes this isn't
efficient there's enough time watch on
it and this happening Albus nuts punish
the fact timing of CLG where he's in a
terrible spot
I would love to save his life it sticks
ace the target though he's trying to run
for his life the very good tempered fate
double stun a little early who he shut
his load too soon
darshan it's down 6a supposed to run for
his life but look at that accelerated
shot boss it's a double kill for Kira
they're pushing CLG they've got baron
and it's a 5 on 2 will these death
timers they can actually try to go for
the win here they are looking to make
the upset over CLG
fifteen but he's gonna spell the tart
here in the midlane most likely calling
is gonna come Annie's pretty optimistic
as here takes another one dozen let's
read the lease and exploit a miracle get
shockwave but that's only one target ego
stay off secure
the only team the LCL representative
have lost you are the tournament
favorites to win if you don't there are
some atrocious guys hidden you need to
prepare to play vs s otherwise you will
lose no matter of your sit one from you
or C - from money where a big deal now
you have to you have to admit it or lose
departments do is just really arriving
at the right time - all these waves Oh
sticks a gets exhausted with boomerang
six legs running for his life tampered
fights look for the target to hit the
target he goes golden liquor it's not
gonna find the stun this time around
stay up use the cocoon Cullen comes up
at six a stunning alone very cool
he's looking for more Smurf kids are
killed CLG are routed they're running
for their lives
Elvis not from the sea is from the LCL
they are doing what no wild card team
has done before Elvis
Chicago
this was their most impressive win by a
wide margin this was a 30-minute stop of
CLG in Russia we don't care about slow
game or if something is the risk or not
the rush which has plays a game because
otherwise it's not interesting nor Faraz
not reviewers so that we just try to do
our best and to entertain you guys as
much as possible
nxr actually deep invading now this is a
beautiful level was gonna go back and
he's gonna fish he can save him and
that'll be fun it's gonna be a big fight
we're going for it actually miss he's
not gonna make it in Berkeley it funds a
bank where they get minor tactics big
play again yes they fail yes they could
do better but but when they get nothing
Alicia had no reason to play they could
just rather they could just go team or
go fool around
yes it would be find apart Zeca Sean's
their competitive spirit and support
until the very end and you know guys
when everyone hates you everyone thinks
that you that you don't deserve to
represent the region and you find the
strength inside of you to fight even if
it doesn't matter oh that's really cool
guys thank you you to feel on the same
time on top is here we go made all of a
sudden the action
Braddock yeah and it's important to note
that rocks does not benefit oh my god
cuz they can't good stomacher it's gonna
get reset on time I've seen coming here
what's up like your aesthetic hirabai
goes up and that's enough for the kill
is in actually feeding the rocks Tigers
right now in the front lines fighting
through the front Memphis gorilla tries
to go but he gets bought by Kofi [ __ ]
again for a beta they get it turn it
around a bit gorilla it goes down all
these paintings are hating to boiling
stones and they credit time
they did
just took down the rocks
Elvis nuts Luna this took down the rocks
Tigers